Allora ragazzi sono parcheggiato
parcheggiato per modo di dire in
stazione centrale ho organizzato una
roba incredibile quando mi sono
trasferito a Milano che avevo quasi 20
anni 19 sul set di Game Therapy gran
film di Spielberg che ricorderete tutti
Ho conosciuto una ragazza Ok che faceva
la comparsa questa ragazza che ho
conosciuto eh Poi siamo stati
sostanzialmente insieme un annetto
Siccome siamo rimasti in buoni rapporti
lei dopo un po' di anni che ogni tanto
ci scambiavamo qualche messaggio mi
scrive No ma tu lo conosci jumbodrillo
mi fa No è uno youtuber mi fa un sacco
ridere Ho pensato che sarebbe stato
veramente cringe organizzare un incontro
tra il buon Judge e la mia ex La cosa
bella di tutto questo è che lei non ne
ha la minima idea
bene Sto morendo Guardate che mi fa
stranissimo questa cosa Però vabbè dico
che io dico lui è lui
già che vedermi guidare per te deve
essere un po' Ma infatti non ti dava mai
fastidio il fatto che io facessi YouTube
facciamo un ranking delle persone Dai
facciamolo facciamolo quindi primo in
Italia coccodrillo
siamo arrivati Ok quello che dobbiamo
fare che c'è questa fattore sorpresa
Quindi ti devo bendare sembra un po' una
roba da 50 sfumature di grigio però non
è accendere un cazzo eh Giampiero allora
ragazzi Sono gasato come una scimmia
rara pronta
Sì mi piace il mio lavoro oggi che
proprio mi sveglio ma ti dico mi piace
fare sti video Stai qua un secondo
adesso noi staremo in silenzio 15
secondi
[Musica]
Allora
ok ok La sedia la senti Perfetto allora
siamo qua mi piace fare questi video è
bellissimo già detto un sacco di volte
ti svenderò e tu tieni ancora gli occhi
chiusi al mio 1 2 3 apri li apri Ok
smonto tutto 3 2 1
[Musica]
appena detto che ti amo Ciao
amore
Certo
No perché abbiamo organizzato tutta sta
roba Ma io non l'ho visto siccome tu
cioè questa cosa qua con Jumbo ho detto
organizziamo un po' una chiacchiera col
Judge è un po' cringe ma è questo che
voglio da questo video voglio Il Grinch
che che esce fuori Capito Allora avevo
pensato di fare una sorta di hai mai
Partecipa anche tu però cioè
[Musica]
Favij e Originals
No dici una cosa hai mai fatto L'hai mai
fatto in spiaggia esempio
beve chi l'ha fatto Chi non l'ha fatto
non bere qui eh stavo già per bene
No
non era nessuno libera eh Tra l'altro
parentesi c'entra un cazzo Io ho fatto
un video con la mia ex ragazzi ma non
c'entra Cioè non è che sto ripercorrendo
la mia storia è il caso incredibile può
far rincontrare tutte le ex assieme Cioè
Avevo pensato per quello che mi sto
bendando prossimo video
partiamo col Judge ormai fatto sesso Eh
già insomma
[Musica]
[Applauso]
andiamo avanti comunque sì ho fatto
sesso poi vabbè è successo devo fare una
valutazione Eh
Mi son perso
la roba da fastidio ma piace non si sa
perché lo metti bellissimo
va bene davanti attenzione
[Musica]
ci sono tante domande vorrei uscire da
questa situazione il prima possibile hai
pensato di sposarti
Qua la domanda è
[Musica]
Sì davvero
[Risate]
in un futuro Sì ci facciamo avevo
pensato anche a quello ci siete mai
annoiarvi durante un rapporto
[Musica]
Vabbè facevo tanti video
quello che penso adesso è un criceto in
effetti
non tipo feticista l'estremo Però mi
piacciono Hai mai leccato un piede mi
piace
le mani le trovo più sinuose esatto
allora Vabbè io sono affezionata quelle
di Lory però aggiungo secondo il tuo
terzo Mi dispiace non bisogna mangiarsi
le unghie
Vorrei mettere un piccantino c'entra un
cacchio con la Maya quindi se ci fosse
la possibilità
non avete niente
[Risate]
Se ci fosse la possibilità
col giudice
siete mai stati traditi
ma io ho letto tutta
però che io sappia avete mai inviato Sì
no c'è qualcuno
penso che riceverai ogni tanto in dm No
io mando andare perché a me non è mai
arrivato niente e io ti seguo
cazzo vado
cani
ricevo e non sono nessuno
il più bello che mi è arrivato è stato
un video di un ragazzo con il collare
che mi diceva mommy No no
mia madre andiamo avanti ragazzi
no cioè all'inizio qualcosa guardavo
però poi
Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti in
questo video io sono Favij non riesco
Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti non
riesco più a farlo
durante l'atto pensato ad un'altra
persona
[Musica]
bene è capitato di pensare asciuga dei
bts con lui no Hahaha
Ma no magari con persone con cui non è
che avessi cioè una mi è capitato non
avevo questo interesse così forte a
livello sentimentale Diciamo che
non sei tu e mi interessa quindi
favorisce
mi piace di più la parte del cioè del
non mi farei mai Tipo ste cose qua Però
mi piace di più stare sotto Passami il
termine capito
Mi piace farmi cavalcare Infatti io
avevo il frustino No non è vero non è
mai successo questa cosa mi piace farmi
dillo
ah ah Basta ragazzi
io sembro la tua ex quella che faceva
sadomaso Ma tu mi avresti mai no
Sì sono molto aperto io non avrei mai
faccia non l'ho mai provato
me lo faccio mettere nel punto ok
Tu l'hai preso No ma io sono sicuro
sicuro vieni qua a dirlo Vieni qua vieni
qua
Ah ah ah Ciccio niente dai dai dai dai
Just Do I noffin al posto Qualcuno
ragazzi Parliamoci chiaro abbiamo 25
anni Facciamo sesso praticamente da
Botto Facciamo 19 Cioè sono passati 6
anni fa sesso da 19 anni prima o poi
approfondire può essere lo strap-on una
via di uscita per fuggire dalla noia o
una vera entrata
avete mai usato il cibo durante un
rapporto l'abbiamo
io non ero io
cosa ho fatto cocomeri cocco
Nutella Nutella
No no no Eccolo là raga
te l'avevo io
ce la Andiamo ragazzi a concludere
questo video
non usciamo malissimo veramente male
bella ragazzi
Wow